[Music]
a woman
sues a man
for ten thousand dollars for failing to
show up to a date as she should damages
as she
should am i right
was it a date where she like paid for
something and they had to cancel so then
she couldn't get a refund you're so
empathetic like i wouldn't even try to
decide in uh no because we believe all
women yeah
what do you think you guys are amazing i
think that guy's a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
i think he [ __ ] up but no before your
question no yeah so it's just for
emotional trauma that's [ __ ] exactly
that's worth 10 jesus that's stupid pain
but real talk though like if you if you
guys knew what it was like to be a woman
and how much they have to work in order
to get ready for the day
dude oh you know 10 000 every time
that's a lot of makeup is expensive yo
[ __ ] shaving that puss shaving that
armpit shaving that leg shaving that
mustache shaving that chin shaving at
everything
then they gotta [ __ ] like shampoo
that hair making that then they gotta
[ __ ] moisturize lotionized then they
got a [ __ ] makeup eye terrorized
pasteurized
[ __ ]
outfit eyes yeah and then like all of
that they haven't even farted and
[ __ ] the whole time
yeah they're holding it in holding it in
when they're on a dude man
you understand the like a woman all of
that [ __ ] just so we could get a boner
just so we could get a bonus all of it
hey that's bravery man
that's really cool you bro thank you so
much thanks for representing so this
michigan woman is attempting to sue a
man for 10 000 us dollars for standing
her up uh the woman named kashante short
has launched a lawsuit against richard
jordan in the 67th district court
claiming quote intentional infliction of
emotional distress after he failed the
show for his date
uh in a video that
that was obtained by media the two
appeared uh via zoom for a virtual
hearing for the court where things
escalated and uh is a video what lawyer
took this [ __ ] case pro bono i'll
take it pro bono that's like some
[ __ ] judge judy's [ __ ] yeah this is
joseph judge joel brown
did she win
uh
we're cutting to we're cutting to the
spoiler right away if i just tell you
the answer right i'm sorry i was just
excited i like that i like that she's
not even fully in frame in the zoom
meeting
but yeah she's too distressed so they're
for real in wait what am i looking at
this is like a zoom court that they're
in appearance imagine the guy getting
served and he reads like what he's
getting sued for oh that was a profile
of her
okay i profile close up like that yeah
she's not even using it the right way
have we gotten that soft that's insane
so um
he literally said in that zooming he to
the judge he's like i don't see uh or no
he says uh to be honest with you i
thought this was just gonna be thrown
out
because he just thought it was dumb
we had a date one date and nothing else
after that and now i'm being sued for
ten thousand dollars i think this is a
waste of your time you say that's gonna
judge the the court's time for sure she
claims that the man lied about going on
a date with her and accused him of
perjury
before the judge surgery what the [ __ ]
is perjury you put your hand on the
bible yeah and then you tell elizabeth
after you put your hand in the bible so
i guess it was more like she was suing
him for not showing up or standing her
up and then when he got into the court
being the court of zoom and he said blah
blah blah now he's saying hey you put
your hand on the oath she's saying like
you just lied under oath because that's
not what happened
so now that perjury is a part of her
complaint not just does it count anymore
since you can't even touch the bible to
swear yeah
you don't have to you can you can touch
anything you touch the webcam like that
is that like just your intention that's
vocalized via recorded like camera you
can touch the yeah you know bible you
need quran are you telling me am a woman
could sue me if i buy a movie ticket
i'll show up if they decide to because
they thought i was going to sit in the
seat you know what though i feel like if
she was like a super rich woman yeah
like if she was a billionaire and then
her time matters that much then i think
that makes sense is she sue for 10 000
yeah if she's like making a billion
dollars every year then
do you i mean if you don't yeah her time
is money yeah
yeah you know so yeah she's a
billionaire if she's a billionaire
wouldn't he also still go to the judge
and be like i think this is a waste of
time
she's a billionaire she's a billionaire
if i was to do i'm like why'd you tell
me you're a billionaire
i wouldn't shut up
i would have been i would have been
there
scooping up all your cash yeah you're
telling me the wrong [ __ ] tell me you
[ __ ] like muffins and [ __ ] give a
[ __ ] dude tell me you're a billionaire
start with that right
start with leave there i'll i'll [ __ ]
marry you now
don't tell me when's the wedding go to
catalina i don't give a [ __ ] dude
the ten thousand is for the pain and
suffering yes yes for for
the emotional distress that was that was
the actual allegation does the judge not
have any other cases to like work on or
something is that how that works because
this is seems like such a well i don't
think it's the judge's fault for
receiving
they can't throw it out there yeah if
she loses the case can she sue the judge
for emotional distress from having lost
the case like where does this end you
know
in america absolutely
yeah the judge did tell the woman that
she had filed to the wrong court
as her claim was a matter outside the
jurisdiction of district court so where
the [ __ ] you need to go feelings court
[Laughter]
supreme yeah supreme court that's what
you gotta go dude you gotta go to the
actual supreme court
dude i want to see this go to the
[ __ ] top
washington dc
[ __ ] straight up you gotta dial 988.
how do they decide if you could sue a
person for something and not you know
yeah that's my question i think it's
just how
deadbeat your lawyer is
i think in america everything is uh
suitable at least once
yeah that's crazy until until it hasn't
been figured out before i think that you
always can win the lawsuit yeah no
precedent i think that's why in in the
states we can't have that much fun
because everything gets [ __ ] by people
who sue like the parks used to be more
dangerous for kids it used to be much
more fun when i grew up and now it's all
[ __ ] soft as [ __ ] they got that
spongy ass like ground [ __ ] they got all
kinds of stupid like i don't know man
it's all plastic if you go to australia
the jungle gyms are way crazier
like where the kids can climb and it
just looks way more funny now that
statistically child deaths are higher at
playgrounds it's not don't matter no i
think they're tougher look at the water
parks just south of the border yeah like
if you go to mexico they should look
like circus cannons that just shoot kids
out yeah dude and it's all good yeah no
one's suing anybody over there mexican
theme parks dude that [ __ ] is like life
or death we're halfway there with like
raging waters and wild rivers
there's like like every single time i
remember going to like raging waters of
wild rivers i would think to myself as
kid i was like dude straight up i'm in
mexico this is like the most mexican
people and i lived in buena park i lived
in porter park so i was always always
around a lot of man they should call
that [ __ ] like calm waters not raging
if you compare to mexico like their
theme parks are out of this world dude
it's probably gotten scaled back even
more now it's probably so expensive like
they remember they started taking diving
boards away from public pools yeah dude
is that crazy they have the two level
ones but how do you [ __ ] up diving boys
have you not seen them on like tick tock
and [ __ ] people have been [ __ ] on
dining boards all the time it's like
illegal in certain cities to have a
diving board in your pool like some
people they don't time it good so they
come down they [ __ ] hit their heads
and that's
the cost of the insurance it's not even
the lawsuit it's like how much more you
have to pay
to have it it's not worth it yeah it's
super not worth it there's like hikes
all over um hawaii right where the
government won't fix it up or do
anything um because if they touch it or
do anything then it's their
responsibility so then volunteers just
get together put their money together
and then they just fix the trail
themselves yeah
but interesting it's one of those
situations where we could have nice
things if people didn't [ __ ] sue all
day [ __ ] america
i do wish there were way less lawsuits
because like the way that you i think we
we subconsciously interact with things
we already know that we're already like
born to understand those things the way
you talk to another person the way you
don't talk to another person to like not
say anything to protect yourself in that
moment the way you need [ __ ] like
text and visual receipts for everything
that you have in order to make sure
every word is said the right way and
you're protected dude the [ __ ] even a
minor but like a fender bender right
like you're getting an accident like you
just want to be a genuine human being be
like oh sorry dude you okay okay
whatever but then like they teach you
don't ever [ __ ] apologize don't even
admit to wrong just deny everything and
then it creates all these like like
hostile situations where everyone's
defensive and they're like no i didn't
do [ __ ] you didn't do no no you did that
no [ __ ] you you're gonna [ __ ] pay for
it now yeah or even if the sue amount if
i give a fender bender right and if it
was like hey i'm gonna sue him he ran
into me for a thousand dollars to fix my
bumper that's normal but for them it's
like oh let's take it to seven figures
because of this this this this and like
what the [ __ ] you made me [ __ ] get
off like emotional damage because i got
triggered after you [ __ ] i wore this
neck brace for eight months when i only
needed it for never because the
chiropractor's in it yeah yeah the
[ __ ] would do everybody's in on it
the mechanics sit on it everyone's there
to [ __ ] heist money with your
insurance company if you if you guys
need a guy i got a guy
i got a car a good car no it's
everything like my buddies have just
accidents insurance fraud you gotta
interrupt homie will just crash into you
go ahead where they'll be like oh yeah
this was stolen this was in the car like
the way they systemize everything it's
like mechanics do that all the time yeah
yeah the shady [ __ ] and then they go
through the chiropractor and then you go
get treatment because you got in a car
accident my back hurts then they're
getting a little chip and everybody wins
there was a there was a time where i
parked my van on on the street in front
of my house and this lady uh swiped it
just like when crunch with her porsche
hit my shitty ass van
and then uh
uh the when i ran outside what was that
noise my neighbor was like yo that lady
just hit your van and she uh was driving
off so i i got in my van and i chased
her and you [ __ ] caught up i thought
we were gonna be like [ __ ] chasing
through the hills she was three houses
down went into her own garage and was
shutting the garage i ran up and i was
looking at her like this
no way bro oh my god
what happened after and she's all like
well you parked so close like you're so
far from the curb and it's like dude my
wheels on top of the curb
so then i i took it to this um i took it
to this mechanic dude in sun valley like
this armenian cat is like super cool and
all she damaged was like
one tiny ass area over my wheel like
super small and he goes
you want to paint the whole van
that's what they do bro and they ask you
they ask you these leading questions oh
what about the rims yeah the rims look
[ __ ] destroyed oh what about your
taillights do you want engine
oh my god this engine is destroyed
oh my god what a drop gsr
like dude it's a chevy vest and he goes
he goes and your macbook was in there
too right the macbook got destroyed
that was the best and i was like ah dude
i don't know man i can't because it was
such a tiny thing but her porsche
cayenne got [ __ ] up because like my
shit's like a 70s van it's all eel and
shame
and i felt bad for her but like i was
like dude she did hit and run and she
did that
i was like yeah it was a hit and run
because i just closed the garage on here
the dude's eyes lit up and he goes even
run
like he started like drooling he did
right and i was like no bro don't do it
he's like you want her house we can get
her house you want to paint your house
too
do you want the new dog
i give you a new life i did it i didn't
go for it you want a wife
he had a he had a friend in insurance
too that was like the guy that uh of
course he damn dude i'm telling you bro
that's how it works people that assess
the damage and they value it yeah he had
an inside guy too and they'll be like oh
this is so [ __ ] up this is really
[ __ ] up yeah yeah yeah but then the
dude came to my house and he like he was
doing the same [ __ ] and he was like you
could paint this whole bad man
[ __ ] cat cause it's so obvious and
i'm like i gotta live next to this lady
it's such a crime though yeah it was a
random person maybe but so you did the
actual
reasonable oh dude i got like fixed up
the whole interior i got like 300 bucks
yeah i got nothing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you